britney spears's father jamie spears
filed a petition to end her
conservatorship this is just a
groundbreaking day in new court
documents filed on tuesday jamie
reportedly states that britney is
entitled to have this court now
seriously consider whether this
conservatorship is no longer required
and in a statement to e.t brittany's
attorney matthew rosengart says the
filing represents a massive legal
victory and vindication for the pop star
rosengart continued it appears that mr
spears believes he can try to avoid
accountability and justice including
sitting for a sworn deposition and
answering other discovery under oath but
as we assess his filing which was
inappropriately sent to the media before
it was served on council we will also
continue to explore all options e.t has
reached out to jaime's attorneys for
comment it's a significant development
and potentially a major victory for
brittany jamie has been in charge of his
daughter's conservatorship for 13 years
tuesday's court filing goes on to say
brittany's circumstances have evolved to
the point where grounds for
establishment of a conservatorship may
no longer exist the news follows last
month's major development when jamie
first hinted in court docs that he was
willing to step down as brittany's
conservator less than two weeks ago we
pledged
that after 13 years of the status quo
my firm and i would move aggressively
and expeditiously
to file a petition to suspend
and remove james p spears
so what comes next for brittany's father
we know that britney's legal team has
stated they plan to continue a vigorous
investigation which will dig into
jamie's conduct throughout the
conservatorship that fits what brittany
herself advocated for during her
bombshell testimony in a hearing earlier
this year in which she compared life in
her conservatorship to sex trafficking
and said her dad as well as others
involved should be in jail jaime has
denied all allegations of abuse against
him following all that public
speculation has centered around what
happens next for jamie once he's removed
and if his court filings have been an
attempt to fight these allegations
he believes he's been smeared in the
media smeared in the court
to be this kind of awful person and he's
trying to fight and say
i'm not what you have all paid me to be
and so
it's unclear at this point what's going
to transpire in the conservatorship
battle but most likely there's probably
going to be some more information that
comes out regarding what he did or did
not do however by agreeing to step down
it does alleviate probably some of the
investigation that he would have to go
under and some of the scrutiny he would
have to undergo if he tried to fight it
and stay as her conservator if he tried
to stay then it would be
a battle of whether he's after his best
interest so then you know britney spears
attorneys would have to try to prove
some of the allegations that they said
are true and it could get really nasty
and so while it is in the best interest
of britney spears according to the
father for him to step down it could
also be in the father's best
reputational interest for him uh to step
aside as well because it could get
really nasty if he were to try to fight
this